the Joe Rogan experience you want some
fake beer it's so than zero
I can't bless ya I mean I don't drink
and this is absurd to me that I would
have a beer it's a fake beer it's not
zero I don't miss the taste of alcohol
what no who misses that no one would
drink alcohol if it didn't get you effed
up I would join these it is good really
yeah I love it
this tastes like the st. Louis funny
bone which is a great taste it does it
taste like the st. Louis funny bone 2009
live in my best lo when was the last
time you drank 2011 December 9th
Cleveland hilarities after the show I'm
done I well I just had a couple beers to
close out the evening was by myself just
gonna go you shooting heroin I don't
know what happened I I well I was at a
point in my life where it was like this
has got us Scott because my hangovers
were getting so ridiculous and
debilitating for a whole day and I was
just doing you know I would black out
from like two drinks because my mind
John Mulaney has a great joke about it
where he says he would black out very
quickly after a couple drinks cuz his
mind was like we know where this is
going shutting down early like if you
know it's gonna be you're gonna black
out your brain just blacks out earlier
right cuz every time I drink I would
black out so I just I woke up that
morning and I had only had a it wasn't a
hard night of drinking couple beers but
I was just the sickest I've ever been
and the thing about hangovers that I
really had to look at was like the best
part about being sick if you're gonna
find the best part about being sick it's
that people feel sorry for you get
babies a little bit you get a nurturing
from your friends and family that you
don't get when you're healthy but when
you're hungover no one gives you that so
you're sick and you don't even get the
only good thing about being sick which
is people feeling sorry for you
everyone's like you piece of [ __ ] you
did this to yourself so I was like in
the shower Anna in the fetal position
thinking this is how I should feel if
I'm dying like I really don't want to
feel this bad unless I am on my way out
so I'm not doing this anymore and I read
a book and when I was done what was the
book either way to stop drinking by Alan
Carr
what's the easy way easy way is you read
this book and then you're done at the
end of it and what he does
well I'd used his method to stop smoking
the easy way to stop smoking by Alan
Carr so many people have read it it's
the one book that when you've tried
everything else nothing else works this
book my mom quit smoking after 35 plus
years no so many of my friends I heard
about it I think like Ellen DeGeneres
and Ashton Kutcher I heard a bunch of
celebrities kind of talking about it I
read the book and you can smoke while
you read it and then by the end of the
book he just promises you he goes go
have a cigarette and you're just like no
I don't want to when I don't need to his
method is and this thing he does with
drinking any excuse you have to do that
thing he talks you out of it he tells
you a reason why your excuse is actually
[ __ ] and there's no science behind
it that and he he disproves any reason
that you have to do it and we've been
brainwashed by tobacco and alcohol
industries to believe that quitting is
really hard and quitting alcohol is hard
if you have an addiction
you can like die from it obviously but
with tobacco it's part of their
propaganda to tell you that it's hard to
quit smoking they are the ones pushing
that must method or message which seems
like why would they tell people it's
hard but they're doing that because if
it's hard you won't quit so that has
been their message to be like it's so
hard to quit smoking it's so hard when
really it's not you know the the
withdrawal symptoms of not smoking lasts
up to two weeks I think it's less than I
think it's like seven to 11 days and the
discomfort caused by wanting a cigarette
is the same discomfort as being a little
bit hungry you're a little bit annoying
it's like it's not insurmountable it's
it's uncomfortable but it's it passes
after seven to eleven days I think it is
and then it's all even when you're going
through it it's not that bad but it's
it's the psychological effect of
thinking it's hard that makes it then
hard mmm so once he proves to you it's
not that hard and any excuse you have to
smoke which is like it calms me down
it raises your blood pressure so that's
inaccurate
um it makes me more social actually it
isolates you you know if you really look
at it every time you smoke you feel kind
of bad people think you staying like it
just every excuse you have and then he
did it with drinking too I went through
this book I read it you can drink while
you read the book you have to want to
quit to pick up the book you have to
want to be like I want this out of my
life I don't know how to get it out of
my life and I gave this book to so many
of my friends and my friends don't drink
anymore and a lot of them you know use
program or other things to supplement
but all I needed was this book and I was
done and I'll tell you I drank every
single night of my life and I never
thought I could live without it it was
just I was just like anyone listening
that's like no no no you don't
understand all my friends drink it's my
life it's my social life it's my work
life it was everything to me it's all I
look forward to yeah I'll never go like
this when my friend enters a bar again
like I'll never do that I will never
greet a friend with she's here yes yes
yes that's you that was me that was like
that's something I miss I'll never have
that kind of to drink enthusiasm anymore
but because I don't drink
I am [ __ ] killing it my life changed
I can trace my careers before and after
like on the dot hmm so you know it's not
for everyone if you have a problem you
should maybe look into it but that book
seriously changed my life that sounds
amazing
and there was no like difficulty in
quitting none no really was easy
I never maybe a couple times I felt like
hah I'd be nice to have a drink
you know I was dating a guy that like
just wanted to have a glass of wine with
me and I'm like well I can't I just have
a glass of wine and I've been tempted
and I don't think that I would go off
the deep end again but but but I don't I
just I go back to that book and I'm just
like I just any reason I can give myself
it's just really it isn't true
and I'm better without it well it's
definitely not true if you're drinking
it every night and you're blacking out
yeah but if you just have a cup of glass
of wine with dinner it feels nice oh I
know lubricant you have fun with friends
start laughing and joking around but you
don't
have that ability to stop there is that
I could for a few months and then it
would trickle into it's just exactly the
voice you at every people are listening
and I know you relate to this of you go
I'm just gonna have to tonight but then
that person and you go promise yourself
you're just gonna have to but then you
get that voice drunk and that voice is
like have another come on you can't talk
to yours
you can't plan for how you're gonna feel
two drinks in because you get drunk and
then you it just keeps going
you miss it man even I have a bit about
that about drunk driving the problems
not the problems not whether or not you
can drive drunk the problem is even
thinking you can drive drunk because
when you're drunk you don't know what
the [ __ ] you can do or can't do yeah I
think that's why guys getting fights is
people way bigger than them when they're
drunk and they don't even know how to
fight you're you're stupider yeah when
you're drunk you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] when
you're drunk so the idea that you could
drive drunk like I'm fine like you don't
even know if you're fine that's the
problem yes the problem is you're drunk
and that's a big part of the book is
talking to people about this liquid
courage that everyone cites I mean link
I need a drink because I can't go
onstage if I don't have a drink I need a
drink to talk to the girl and it's not
courage what you're doing is you're
making yourself more stupid
[Applause]